l'assurance maladie des yvelines lance
son tout premier escape game pour les
jeunes vendredi 1er avril une première
édition était organisée à la maison de
l'étudiant de l'université de versailles
saint quentin en yvelines l'objectif est
dé amelia se souvenir de ce qu'elle a
fait la veille 1 soirée cet esclave
gamme est composée en deux zones une
première zone sera consacré à toutes les
questions sur le jeu nature et social à
quoi sert d'assurance maladie à quoi
sert ma carte vitale les taux de
remboursement et à la fin de ce premier
parcours ils auront une clé pour accéder
à une deuxième zone qui sera la zone
prévention
dans cette deuxième zone les étudiants
doivent résoudre des énigmes et des
codes pour remonter le moral d'amélie
celle ci a fait une soirée avec beaucoup
d'excès la veille et elle ne se souvient
plus si elle a consommé de la drogue ou
si elle a eu un rapport sexuel protéger
monsieur la coque
au total ils ont quinze minutes pour
trouver cinq énigmes sur la drogue les
maladies sexuellement transmissibles le
tabac ou encore le cannabis c'était
intéressant parce que ça nous a permis
bad apprendre un peu plus sur certains
sujets qu'on connaissait pas forcément
franchement super c'est très bien j'ai
appris plein de choses intéressantes
telles que même les maladies
on sexuellement transmissibles que c'est
génial on devrait aussi passer ça nous
apprend alors les 16 25 ans pour nous
c'est une cible très difficile à aborder
et là ça nous rend un peu plus attractif
on peut aborder ces sujets qui peuvent
paraître assez lourd au quotidien à
aborder et ça va nous permettre de mieux
les accompagner et mieux les
sensibiliser
susan eng un petit peu ludique mais tout
en passant nos messages de prévention et
en les mettant en lien avec les
structures qui peuvent les occupe d
accompagner après alan est effectivement
à la fin de l'escale game de nombreux
partenaires étaient présents pour
répondre aux questions des étudiants sur
la santé sexuelle ou des addictions
d'une durée de 30 minutes environ est
entièrement gratuit il s'agissait d'une
première édition mais l'assurance
maladie des yvelines n'exclut pas de
réitérer l'expérience dans les prochains
mois